some pretty big news for las vegas in
the nfl there is talk that the super
bowl could be coming to our city ron
futrell joining us now with the details
ron yeah here we go denise we've known
for a while that the nfl has had its
sights set on las vegas and putting a
super bowl in our city it looks like
this will become a reality sooner
rather than later the 2024 super bowl is
set for new orleans february 11 2024 but
there's a conflict with mardi gras that
weekend when the nfl went to a 17-game
schedule it pushed the game back a week
created a conflict with new orleans so
las vegas has been mentioned often as a
possible replacement for new orleans in
that year super bowl 58 is on the nfl's
agenda for later this week now during
the owners meetings is when this is
going to take place in exchange new
orleans would get super bowl 59 a year
when mardi gras actually begins in march
so the nfl will hold its pro bowl in las
vegas this february then the nfl draft
in april and oh by the way the 2024
super bowl which will be super bowl 58
will be on cbs another thing that makes
us smile here again february 11 2024 is
only 798 days away tom brady would be 47
years old denise oh thanks for those
numbers ron the